yeah there's some guy who found this
shark that's like one of the or i don't
even know if it's a shark it's like a
supposed to be like one of the oldest
animals left on earth and it looks like
a [ __ ] dinosaur but it's in the water
it's in the everglades i mean how they
gonna know that they've only they've
only discovered or charted five percent
of the ocean i mean like we don't know
well you said something earlier about
aliens coming out of the ocean yeah i
think that's the place that's what yeah
first of all it's hard to get here from
outer space you know what i mean like
what we're talking about here we don't
know that we don't know what space is
well did you see the video that came out
yeah where there was uh it was like a
navy video and it showed like a the like
uh unidentified and it just went
straight into the water yeah dude i'm
saying there's we've only discovered
five percent of the ocean at this point
like
they're coming from the bottom trip this
true story yeah
my grandma's sister's husband yeah
his name's uh doc is dead now
was one of the original
nasa scientists okay
my mom went and visited him like 20
years ago or some [ __ ] yeah hidden
figures they live in maryland
and uh my mom asked him
if aliens were real okay
he said he couldn't answer the question
what year was that she asked him it's
probably in the 90s okay so you were
alive i was alive okay um and she and he
but she he told her
i can't answer that question but if
people knew what was in the ocean they'd
want to kill themselves
[Laughter]
and i i heard my mom told me this like
when i was like i don't know 10 11 or
something and i was like damn that [ __ ]
always stuck with me
and uh you know he passed away but he
was like
oh gee nasa og nasa yeah oh geez damn
so how crazy bro so every time i see
some ocean [ __ ] i'm like man
the ocean got some [ __ ] in it ocean got
some [ __ ] bro
i mean like we should be talking to
animals we should be talking to animals
and stop worrying about this other [ __ ]
so we can [ __ ] fight the aliens that
are coming from the bottom of the ocean
real talk i think they're already here
man no they've been here yeah yeah
they've been here like you saw the new
uh suicide squad they've been here